hey everyone it's Mike from waterflow
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you can join me for today's video
we're going to be talking about um when
what doesn't happen in the market that
happens so basically you know you see
something that should be bearish and
that market actually rallies or
something that should be bullish and the
market sells off um what's that mean and
what's the importance but uh before we
jump in you know if you've been enjoying
my videos before be sure to subscribe
and click the notification Bell so you
don't miss any new uploads and if you
find today's video helpful be sure to
hit the like button and leave a comment
sharing your biggest takeaway I love
hearing your feedback you know the
weekend's coming up so I'll have a
chance to get through uh some of your
comments and and reply to them your
support really does go a long way in
helping me create more content just like
this so if you're getting value from my
channel want to see more be sure to
subscribe and we'll grow together all
right
so you know in my weekly uh training
session for users of my my software this
question sort of came up in a in a way
where when you expect something to
happen in the market based off of the
order flow okay so meaning there's
bullish order flow but the market sells
off or you have um bearish order flow
and instead the market rallies why is
that happening and you know I'm sort of
going to take you through a couple
examples and and show you um a basic one
now you know order flow is so robust
right you have Delta you have point of
control you have imbalances and probably
the easiest way for me to show you this
and this is not the only way but the
easiest example that I could show you is
with stacked buying and selling
imbalances okay so you know if you're
not familiar with what a stacked buying
and balance is it's basically three
buying and balances stacked neatly on
top of each other now it doesn't have to
be three but minimum is is three for
most Traders um three four five 6 7 you
know if you have two usually that that's
not enough to qualify um as a stacked in
Balance like you got two buying balances
here really you want to see three or
more and generally you know after you
see a stacked buying IM balance right
the market will rally generally if you
have a stack selling IM balances which
is three or more selling imbalances
stack neatly on top of each other the
market will sell off you know here sort
of sold off a little bit then turned
around and rallied see the aggressive
buying coming in you got a stack buying
and balance and the market went up
however there are times when you have
something like this
happen got the red candle pushes down
you got the selling imbalance at the
bottom of the bar and the market rallies
we will say you know a overlow it's a
scam doesn't matter it doesn't mean
anything um because you see here you got
aggressive selling and and the market
rallied well you need to stop and think
about what's taking place in the market
right there's so many different Traders
trading for whatever reason some Traders
are getting into a position some Traders
are getting out of a position and you
know and it's something that gets lost
on a lot of Traders you know for example
you know traders that like to look at
you know the the market depth map they
see liquidity up here they see liquidity
down here and they automatically assume
that's Traders getting into a position
like oh there's a big seller up here
right they're not going to let the
market go above it well who knows maybe
that person bought from down here and
they're just taking profits they're
happy to leave it in there for when the
market comes there that's why you know
the this resting liquidity that everyone
thinks is going to hold doesn't hold
because it could just be somebody
getting out of the position and you know
it's nice to think that every order is
somebody getting into a position but at
the same time there are people
constantly getting out of positions okay
and one order by
itself may not have any effect on the
market meaning now orders like for
retail Traders like all of us out here
um and I say all of us meaning you know
unless you're an Institutional Trader
working for a bank or a hedge fund or a
trading firm then you're professional or
institutional Trad I don't say
professional but institutional Trader
meaning you trade big size okay so for
example as just selling in Balance here
99 140 14 so what is that that's about
250 contracts is that for a big
Trader that's not a whole heck of a lot
right they they routinely trade 500 700
750 1,000 2,000 e minis no problem okay
and this could just be a big order that
went through the market someone said oh
yeah you know what just sell me 250 at
the market okay you know they know 250
is generally going to be swallowed up by
the market pretty easy it's not going to
have much effect on the market and maybe
they're just getting out of a position
maybe they're just um
what do you call it you know working
it Delta one trade right they're working
it against something else or or maybe
who knows we don't know what is going on
in the mind of the trader that executes
that we could make a guess that's all we
can do unless we're the actual Trader
that is trading that order okay so what
do you have let's take it a step back
what do you have okay I got a market
it's kind of going I don't say going up
but right we had a low here hit it again
here we're starting to go up we got this
push down here
okay why right this is what you got to
do as a Trader you have to think about
sometimes of of what is going on in the
market why is something trading and in
this case it's a bearish order flow
right it's a selling IM balance it's a
big order that's going through the
market I don't want to say it's a stop
because it's in an area that we had just
been trading a few minutes before no one
is going to you know get long in here
and put a stop you know a tick or two
below where they got long so it's
probably just a someone getting out of a
position I don't care just get out okay
I I don't think it's fresh selling
because we had just been selling you
know trading in there
earlier so to me it's just someone
getting out of a position now okay fine
if I'm going to make that Assumption of
somebody getting out of a
position to me that should have really
no effect on the overall trend of the
market right now at the same time when
you see something like this right
everyone always likes to use the term
trapped Traders oh the market went up
because Traders got trapped here okay
again it's 250 contracts this bar traded
3,600 contracts these price levels some
of them are trading over 250 contracts
so again saying the market is rallying
because there's Traders trapped down
here usually when when you have
something like this it's not
overwhelming Bond it's not like 9,000
contracts are trading down here here and
everyone that was selling it down in
into these prices are getting stuck no
it's just to me this is just a big order
that went through the
market Ian w't call 250 lots a big order
but it's probably just an order that
went through the market somebody you
know hedging something or getting out of
a position and it's not really having
any effect however it is bearish order
flow okay and I have to keep that in
mind because it is normally I'm seeing a
stack sell in a balance I'm going to see
some follow through right here we we did
go a little bit lower but we're not
going any lower in fact this bar even
though it's still a red candle it did
close um off of its low right it's not
closing somewhere down near its low and
it's definitely closing
above the stack Sala balance okay so I
have a stack Salena balance which on the
surface is generally bearish information
and I see the market is just completely
ignoring
it
and the this sort of comes back to a
more broad
General um statement then generally if
you're you're in a market that's
got directional
flow especially a technical market right
because generally if a market is um I
say directionless but not but is
following the technical analysis of the
markets you know like trend lines and
triangles or all that other stuff um
that's like a normal Market condition
but when the market is trending it will
sort of ignore and plow through whatever
technical levels um exist okay and same
thing with orderflow if you have bearish
order flow and the market is not
respecting it for whatever reason again
in this case to me this reason is just
someone um getting out of a position
nothing more it's telling me that hey
you know what even though we got this
bearish
information the Market's ignored it
already right because again if if the
market was thinking that this is like an
important order going through the market
market technically should be trading a
little bit lower so if I see a stack
sell in a balance and the market instead
is trading above it at least immediately
in the next bar right that's not a good
sign you want to see a stack sell a
balance like here and the market trading
below it but if I'm seeing that market
just completely ignores it to me that's
an important piece of information okay
because again you know when when the
market when you have expectations in the
market for something to happen happen
based off your analysis and it doesn't
um it's crucial okay you have to be
prepared for that basically because now
it doesn't mean that your your order
flow is wrong or your analysis is is
completely wrong but it's feedback from
you're getting
feedback immediately from the
market that there's something else going
on okay because again if something else
is going on you know sort of a bigger
thing
then when what you expect to happen
doesn't
happen you go with what is happening
right so why I say you know orderflow is
best utilized as soon as possible Right
you want to take advantage of it and
this is immediate feedback from the
market stack selling imbalance should be
bearish Market keeps going up what do
you think you want to do you want to be
long okay let's take a look here at the
NASDAQ cuz you're going to see it more
in in markets that are a little bit more
volatile like uh mnq or NQ
um here let's let's go take a look here
how manyy do we got here now this is a
30 second chart I use a 30 second chart
on NASDAQ just because it's a bit
volatile here similar thing this one was
9288 or
something yeah 928 this morning let me
just go back to that e mini see what
time that was
here same time 928 so again Marcus
generally
correlated right stack selling a balance
Market went up right let's take a look
at
earlier okay stack buying in Balance
Market went up that's what you expect to
see stack selling in Balance Market went
down that's what you expect to see but
look at this right here 9:00 well
there's a couple here down here this is
853 right let me expand this chart up a
bit
more Market's selling off boom then it
just pukes out somebody just came in ah
just get me out of my position stack
sell in Balance okay why isn't the
market going down right Market's been
trading a little bit lower broke out
down here maybe it's maybe there's some
stops who knows whatever but that's
bearish information and instead the
market rallied
so next bar we're trading inside right
we got a big red candle down next bar
can't go any lower can't even take out
the low of the previous bar Market
starts to Rally that is your sign to get
long the market is giving you immediate
feed back you have bearish order flow
coming in here but the Market's not
going down instead it's going up that's
your sign to be getting long and look at
this it it goes from you know 9904
basically all the way up we hit the new
highs up
here I don't know no it's not the highs
of the day but it's it's a nice move
it's a 50p point move got all the way up
to 54 I'm not saying you'd get 50 points
maybe you get 20 that's great then you
got a stack buying inbalance up here
green candle this is the
opposite strong aggressive buyers right
here look at the top of this bar you got
stack buying IM balance in here stack
buying IM balance in here continues
powering on get up here who knows maybe
it's a stop that just got triggered up
here Market went up came back down next
bar trading below that stack buying
imbalance it opened near its high traded
up two ticks to the bottom of that stack
buying a balance then sold off closed on
its low what do you think the market is
telling you it's not interested in
transacting at these prices up here so
again bullish information up here just
as the previous bar hey I got a stack
buying in Balance I maybe Market can go
higher I got a stack buying in Balance
what Market telling you now no we're not
going higher the Market's reversing and
even if you just traded for 30 seconds
in this bar here you got short on the
open at
942 where' it close 928 and a
half you know what is that fif uh 14
points 12 points 13 points in 30 seconds
right Market often gives you this
immediate feedback now here is one right
Market did start to go up right stack
selling a balance expect the market to
go down Market went up okay closed back
down inside here again it's a little bit
different than the previous bar where
stack buying and balance in here and
then the next bar was just a huge bar
down at least this one sort of retraced
it back even though it was still a green
one okay and again you know again if
you're buying it in here at 933 you get
stopped out here at at 928 a half okay
fine but you want to catch These Bars
like this big one down here right or
moves obviously like I mean you can
catch this bar here just if you caught
just this one bar here you you know
getting long here at 04 till 11 maybe
carried into the next bar to 15
16 you know these sort of Trades happen
all the time now I'm just using stacked
imbalances as one way there's there's
other things in the order flow that also
give you signs like this but you know
it's just easier to talk about stacked
in balances because most of us are
already familiar with them okay but all
the other information you know point of
controls can be used um Deltas can be
used Max M Deltas um you know order flow
information is so robust and and that's
the beauty of orderflow not many Traders
are using it I mean who would get long
off of this bar here this red candle
then this green candle who would get
long off of that not many Traders but if
you're looking at the order
flow you know okay so thanks for
watching this video again if you got
something useful out of it be sure to
leave a comment down there give me a
thumbs up you know in the comments say
hey good job nice video um you know or
if you disagree say I I I disagree with
what you say okay fine that's what makes
the markets disagreements you know if
everyone agreed the markets wouldn't
move it would just trade one price so
thanks for watching being a part of my
orderflow community and I'll catch you
guys on the next video
bye-bye